how the economy works in 30 minutes
the economy worked like a simple
machine but many people do not
understand it or disagree on how it
works
and this conduit had
economic suffering is useless I feel a deep
responsibility to share my
simple but practical  economic model
although unconventional it has helped me
to predict and avoid the
global financial crisis and it works well for
me for over 30 years we
start despite the economy seems
complex it works in a simple and
mechanical way it is composed of a few
simple parts and known simple transactions that
are  they repeat millions of
times over and over again these transactions are
mostly driven by human nature and
we create three main forces that
drive the economy number 1
productivity growth number 2
short term debt cycle and number 3
long term debt cycle
we will look at these three forces and  how
superimposing them creates a good model
to follow the movements  economics and
understand what is happening at the moment we
start with the simplest part
of the economy transactions an economy
is nothing more than the sum of the
transactions that make it up
is a transaction is a very
simple thing you do transactions
continuously every time you  buys
something you create a transaction each
transaction consists of a buyer
who exchanges money or credit with a
seller of goods, services or financial activity
the credit acts as a currency so
by adding the money spent and the amount
of credit used, you can know
the total expense
.  'total amount spent pulls the
economy if you divide the amount
spent by the quantity sold you get
the price this epic
this is a transaction is the basis of
the economic machine all cycles and
all forces in an economy are driven by
transactions
so if we can understand the
transactions we can understand
the whole economy or market consists of
all the buyers  and all the sellers
that transact for the same thing
for example there is a grain market a
car market a stock market
in the markets for millions of things
an economy consists of all the
transactions in all its markets if
you  sum the total expenditure and the
total quantity sold in all markets is
all that is needed to understand
the economy is extremely simple
people companies banks and governments all
take part in transactions in the manner
described by exchanging money and credit
for goods, services and activities  financials
the largest buyer and seller is the
public sector which consists of two
important parts
a central government that
moves spends money and a
central bank that is different from other
buyers and sellers because it controls
the amount of money and credit
in
the economy.  by maneuvering interest rates and
printing new money
for these reasons, as we will see, the
central bank is an important player  Long
in the credit flow
I want you to pay attention to
credit and credit to the most important part of the
economy is probably
the least understood at the most
important part because it is the largest part
is constantly and queer entities and sellers
go to the market to transact
so do creditors and
debtors who lend money usually
want to turn what they have into more
money and those who get into debt usually want
something they couldn't afford
a house or a car or want to
invest in something like starting
a
business credit  can help both lenders
and borrowers get what they
want borrowers promise to
pay back the borrowed sum
called principal plus an
additional sum called interest when
interest rates are high you take out
less loan because it is expensive when
interest rates are low  and you
borrow more because it costs less
when debtors promise to repay
creditors believe it creates
credit no people can agree
to create credit out of thin air this
seems simple enough but credit is
difficult because not different as
soon as credit is created it
immediately converts into debt debt is both
an activity for the lender  that a
liability to the borrower in the future
when the borrower pays off the loan
plus interest
the asset and liability disappear and
the transaction is closed then why
credit is so important because when
a borrower receives credit, the
spending power increases and you remember the expense
drives the economy
this happens because a
person's spending and income for another person
think about every dollar you spend
someone earns and every dollar you
earn someone spends
so when you spend more someone
earns more when
someone's income goes up  creditors are more
inclined to lend you money because now
america the more credit a debtor a  good
credit two things the ability to
repay and
guarantees having a lot of income in relation to his
debt gives him the ability to repay if
he cannot repay assets of
marketable value to use as collateral
this puts lenders
who lend money at ease so  a higher
income allows a higher
indebtedness which allows to
increase spending and since the expenditure of one
person was editor of another
this leads to an increase in debt and
so on this model of self-
strengthening brings economic growth and
for this we have cycles in  a
transaction you have to give something to
get something in the long run
how much you receive depends on how much you
produce over time we learn and that
accumulated knowledge increases our
living standards
we call this
productivity growth inventive and diligent
increase productivity and standard of
living more  quickly of those who are
indolent and lazy but this is not always
true in the brev  and period productivity is
important above all in the long term
but credit is especially important in the short term
this because the
photo-beloved productivity growth therefore is not the author of large
economic fluctuations debt exists
because it allows us to consume more
than what we produce when we buy
and  it makes us consume less than
we produce when we pay it back
its fluctuations occur in two
big cycles one takes about 58 years and
the other about 75 100 years
most people experience
fluctuations but generally don't see them
as chick lit because  see
too closely day by day
in this chapter let's step
back and look at these three great
forces and how they interact to
make up our experiences as
mentioned the fluctuations on this line
are not due to how much innovation or
hard work there
is for the  more due to how much credit
there is that we imagine for a moment a
creditless economy in q  his
economy the only way to increase
my spending is to increase my income
which requires me to be more productive
and do more work an
increased productivity is the only way to grow
as my spending and income for
another person
l  'economy grows every time I or
someone else is more productive
if we follow the transactions and let them
unfold we see a progression as
the productivity growth line
but since we get into debt there are cycles
this is not due to any law but
human nature  and the way
credit works
think of the loan as an
easy way to push spending to have
something you can't afford you
have to spend more than you
earn to do so essentially you have to go into
debt to yourself in the future
by doing this you create a period in the
future in which you will spend less than what
you earn to pay it off soon it
takes the form of a cycle
in a nutshell every time  when you get into debt you
create a cycle this is true for an
individual and for the economy
that is why understanding credit is so
important because it sets in motion a
mechanical and predictable series of events
that will happen in the future
this makes credit different from
money with the  coin close
transactions when you buy a beer from
a bartender for cash the transaction is
closed immediately but when he bought it and
credit it is like opening an account at the bar he
says he promises to pay in the future
together you and the bartender create
a business and  a liability
now you have created credit out of thin air until
you pay the bill the assets and
liabilities go away the debt does not
go away and the transaction does not close
the reality is that most of
what people call money and credit
the amount  total credit in the
united states is about 50 trillion
dollars and the total amount of money is
only about 3 trillion dollars
remember in a creditless economy
the only  way to increase your
spending and produce more but in
a credit economy you can also
increase your spending by indebtedness v as
a result an economy with higher
spending credit and allows incomes to rise
faster than productivity in the short
term but not in the long term  term
now don't get me wrong credit is not
always something bad it only causes
cycles it is bad when it inflates consumption
that cannot be repaid however it is
good when resources are allocated
efficiently that income is produced
in order to pay off debt
for example  just go into debt to buy
a big TV you don't generate
income that makes you pay off the debt
but if you take out a loan for a
tractor and that tractor makes you have
raised more earn more money
then you can pay off your debt and
improve your standard of living
in a  economy with credit we can
follow the transactions and see how
credit creates growth
let me do u  For example,
suppose you earn $ 100,000 a
year and have no debt you have
enough credit
to borrow $ 10,000
from say a credit card so
you can spend $ 110,000 even if you
only earn 100,000 because your
spending and income are  another person
someone earns 110,000 dollars
the person who earns 110,000
debt-free can borrow
11,000 so he can spend and 121,000 even
if he has only earned 110,000 his
expense and another's income and
following the transactions we see how
this process  works in a
self-strengthening model but remember
borrowing creates cycles and if the
cycle goes up sooner or later it has to go down
this takes us into the
short term debt cycle as activity grows
we see an expansion
the first phase of the
short term debt cycle  term expenditure continues to
rise and prices begin to rise
this happens because the increase in
expenditure is alim  credit and can
be created from nothing the instant when
the amount of expenditure and incomes
grow faster than the production of
commodities prices rise when prices
rise we set inflation
the central bank does not want too much
inflation for which causes problems
seeing the  prices go up raise
interest rates with higher interest
rates fewer people can afford
to borrow and the cost of
existing debt goes up
think about it when monthly payments
on your credit card go up
as people take out fewer loans for
repayments than  higher debt to less
money left to spend so spending
goes down and as one person's spending is another person's income and income goes down and so on
when people spend less prices go down
we call this deflation
economic activity goes down  and
we have a recession
if the recession becomes too severe
and inflation is no longer a
problem ab central bank  will lower
interest rates to make everything go up
again with low interest rates
debt repayments are reduced
and debt and spending resume and
we see another expansion as you can
see the economy works like a
machine in the debt cycle  in the short
term spending is limited only by the willingness
of creditors and debtors to give and
receive credit when credit is
readily available there is an
economic expansion when credit is not
readily available
there is a recession and you notice that this
cycle is controlled  mainly from
the central bank
the short term debt cycle
usually lasts 58 years and repeats over and
over for decades but note that the
base is the apex of each cycle they end up
with more growth than in the
previous cycle and with more debt because
why people push him
to borrow and spend more
instead of repaying is human nature
because of this long period of his
id  bits are rising faster than
incomes creating the
long-term debt cycle
despite people getting more and more
indebted lenders extend
credit even more freely because
because everyone thinks things are
going great people
just focus on the events and what
happened  incomes have
risen lately assets values grow the s
ock market is roaring is a boom it is wo
th buying goods services and finan
ial assets with borrowed money when
eople go too far it is called a bubble so ev
n if debts have been growi
g incomes have grown  almost
so fast as to offset them
we call the debt-to-
income ratio the debt burden as long
as incomes continue to rise
the debt burden remains manageable at the
same time asset values
eople borrow huge
ums of money to buy asset
such as  investments causing a
rise in pr  ezzi even more
people feel rich
so even with the accumulation of a lot
of debt
the increase in income and
assets helps the debtors to enjoy
the credit for a long time but this
obviously cannot continue forever
and does not do so in the  Over decades
debt burdens slowly increase
creating more and more
debt repayments at some point and
debt repayments start growing
faster than incomes forcing
people to reduce their spending and
since a person's spending is
income of  another person but incomes
start to go down
which makes people less
creditworthy and makes loans go down
debt repayments keep
going up which leads to further drop in
spending and the cycle reverses this is
peak debt  long-term
debt burdens became too
big for the united states europe and
much of the rest of the world this happened
in 2008
.  de for the same reason it
happens in japan in 1989 and in the
united states in 1929 now the economy
starts deleveraging in
deleveraging people cut
spending incomes fall credit disappears
asset prices  banks
fall under pressure the stock market collapses
social tensions increase and everything
begins to feed itself in the other
direction
as income falls and
debt repayments rise debtors are
under pressure no longer
creditworthy credit goes out
debtors cannot  more
borrow money for debt repayments
struggling to fill this hole
debtors have to sell assets
the rush to sell assets takes over
the market
at the same time spending drops this is
the time when the stock market
collapses housing market reservoirs
banks
the value of the guarantees that i  The borrower
can offer a drop
this makes borrowers even less
creditworthy people feel
poor and credit disappears quickly less
expense less income less wealth less
credit less loans is so on
is a vicious circle this looks similar to
a recession but the difference  here is
that interest rates cannot
be lowered to save the day
in a recession lowering
interest rates pushes into
debt however
in deleveraging
lowering interest rates doesn't
work because interest rates
are already low  and soon they go to
zero percent then the stimulus ends
interest rates in the united
states hit zero percent during
the deleveraging
of the 1930s and again in 2008 the
difference between a recession and a
deleveraging is  that
in this case the debt burdens are
simply magnified and the vialli cannot be
reduced  interest rate
ion lenders understand debts
have become too large to be
repaid in full debtors have
lost their ability to repay and
their collateral the value feel
paralyzed by debt no longer want to
know creditors stop lending
debtors stop borrowing
think of the economy as not creditworthy
just like an individual so
what you do to deleverage
the problem is debt burdens
are too high and have to go down
there are four ways in which  this can
happen 1 people corporations and governments
cut their spending
two debts are reduced through bankruptcies
restructuring 3 wealth is
redistributed from circles to the
poor and finally 4 the central bank
prints new money these four ways
have happened in every
deleveraging  in modern history
, spending is usually cut first
as it has  just seen people
business banks even governments tighten their
belts and cut spending to
pay off their debt
this is often referred to as austerity
when debtors stop taking
new loans and start paying
old debts the burden is expected
debt falls but the opposite happens
as spending is cut and
one person's spending is another's income causes
incomes to fall
faster than debts are
repaid and the debt burden
actually worse  as we have seen
this
deflationary and painful spending
cut companies are forced to cut
costs which means fewer jobs
and increased unemployment
this takes to the next step
debts have to be reduced many
debtors cannot repay their
debts
and debts of  a debtor are assets
of a creditor when debtors do not
repay the
bank people think the bank cannot
repay them co  yes they rush to
withdraw their money from the bank and
banks are under pressure and people
companies banks don't pay their debts
this severe economic downturn is a
depression most of a depression
consists of people discovering the
world of what they thought it was  his
wealth is gone let's go back to when
you bought a beer and put it
on the bill at the bar you promised to
reimburse the bartender your promise
has become a bartender's business but
if you violate the promise if you don't
pay it back you are  defaults on your
bar account then the asset that has in
effect worth nothing has
substantially disappeared
many lenders do not want the
assets to disappear and accept debt
restructuring debt restructuring
means creditors are paid off less I have
paid off over a period of time
longer or at a lower interest
rate than previously agreed in
some way the cont  rat is hacked to
reduce
debt lenders prefer to
have a little something all of
nothing even if debt disappears
debt restructuring makes
income and asset values disappear faster so that the d
bt burden continues to worsen as th
spen
cut debt relief is painful and
deflationary all of this impacts
the central government because
lower incomes and less employment means
the government collects less taxes
at the same time it needs to
increase spending because
unemployment has increased
many of the unemployed  have
inadequate savings and need
financial support from the government
furthermore governments create
stimulus plans and increase their spending to
compensate for the weakening economy
government budget deficits
explode in
deleveraging because they spend more than
how much they earn in taxes this is that
What happens when you hear about the
budget deficit on the news to
finance their deficits governments
have to raise taxes or
borrow money but with falling incomes and
so many unemployed from who gets the
money from the old since
governments need to  more money and that
wealth is highly concentrated in the
hands of a small percentage of
people governments naturally
raise taxes on the rich
which facilitates a redistribution
of wealth for the economy
from the environment to the have-nots the have-
nots who are suffering begin
to experience  dislike of
moneyed circles the rich haves under
pressure from the weak economy the
fall in asset values
taxes reciprocate the dislike of the hapless if co
tinued depression can erupt socia
disorder not only incre
ses tensions within  countries but
may arise between countries especially
debtor and creditor countries
l  he situation can lead to
political change which can sometimes
be strange
in the 1930s this led to hitler in
power war in europe and
depression in the us pressure to do
something to stop depression
escalate
remember most of what
people thought  money was in fact
credit so when credit
disappears people don't have enough
money people are desperate
for money and remember that
the central bank prints money
having already lowered interest rates
to almost zero and is forced to
print
money unlike the  spending
cuts debt reduction and
wealth redistribution printing money is
inflationary and stimulating
inevitably the central bank prints
new money out of thin air and uses it to
buy financial assets and government
bonds that happened in the united states
during the great depression and again
in 2008 when  the central bank of the
united states the federal  print reserve
over two trillion dollars
other central banks all over the world
that had the faculty printed a lot of
money buying financial assets with
this currency it favors the increase in the
prices of goods which makes people more
creditworthy
however this only helps those who
they have financial assets the central bank
can print money but can only
buy financial assets
the central government instead can
buy goods and services issue
money in the hands of the people but cannot
print it so in order to stimulate
the economy
the two must cooperate by buying
government bonds  the central bank
essentially lends money to the government
allowing it to run in deficit and
increase spending on goods and services
through its stimulus programs and
unemployment benefits
this increases public income
and government debt
however lowers the burden  of the
economy's total debt
this is a very risky time i
policy makers must
balance the four ways
debt burdens come
down deflationary methods must
balance with inflationary methods
to maintain stability when balanced
correctly there can be a nice
deleveraging now deleveraging
can be horrible or  beautiful how
deleveraging can
be beautiful even if deleveraging a
difficult situation manage it in the best possible way
beautiful much nicer than
unbalanced excesses of the leverage phase
fueled by debt in a beautiful
deleveraging debts decrease compared
income positive real economic growth
and inflation is not a
problem is achieved with the right
balance
the right balance requires some
combination of cutting that spending
debt relief transfer of
wealth and printing money so
that  economic and social stability
can be maintained people ask if
printing money will increase inflation
not if it compensates for the decline in credit
spending paid with credit
by printing money
the central bank can compensate for the
loss of credit with an increase
in the amount of money to change
things
the central bank needs not only to
stimulate income growth but
to raise the rate of
income growth more  interest rate on
accumulated debt then what do I
mean by this basically
income needs to grow
faster than debt for example
suppose a country that through
deleveraging has
a debt to income ratio of 100
percent
this means that  the
amount of debt he has is the same as the
amount of income that the whole
country produces in one year  or now think
about the interest rate on this debt
let's say it is 2 percent
if the debt rises to 2 percent because
of this interest rate and income
only goes up by about one percent you
can never reduce the  debt burden it is
necessary to print enough money
to push the growth rate of
income above the interest rate
however it is easy to blame the printing
of money because it is immediate and
people prefer it to alternatives
the key is to avoid printing
too much money and  trigger a
ramp inflation you and there is germany during
deleveraging in
the 1920s
if politicians to add the right
balance
deleveraging is not that dramatic at
slow growth but debt burdens
come down is a nice reduction  leverage
when incomes rise debtors
begin to look more
creditworthy and when debtors seem more
creditworthy lenders  i
start lending money debt burdens
finally go down but being able to
borrow money people can spend
more eventually the economy starts to
grow again leading to the
reflation phase of the long term debt cycle
even though the process
of deleveraging  financial and it can
be horrible if managed if
managed well it will end up solving the
problem
it takes about a decade more for
the debt burdens to go down and
the economic activity to return to
normal hence the term lost decade of
course the economy is a little longer
complicated than this model
suggests however placing the
short-term debt cycle on the
long-term debt edge and then placing
both above the productivity growth line
by a
reasonably good model to see where
we have been where we are now
and where we are likely to go  in
summary there are three rules of thumb that
I would like you to incorporate from this first not
the  know that debt saga sooner
than income because your
debt burdens will eventually crush you
second don't let income
go up faster than productivity
because you will eventually become
uncompetitive and third
do whatever you can to increase
productivity because a  in the long run
this is what matters most
this is simple advice for you
and policy makers
you may be surprised never again including
the majority of policy makers
do not go enough this
model has worked for me and I hope and will
work for you thank you